foreign
[Music]
to the pretty intense podcast today is
pretty intense for sure I mean the the
guest is Matthias de Stefano and he's a
guy that remembers all of his past lives
he just knows the history of the planet
with Atlantis and lemuria and Egypt and
you know all the places that are just so
interestingly ancient and he remembers
all that stuff I gotta say that's not
really what we talked about what we
talked about was I say it's pretty
intense but it actually was a really
peaceful conversation you know we got to
the point of what this reality is about
like what we're here to do and what
created us and and how we evolve well
the message is just so peaceful but also
like riveting and fascinating and
informational he just is able to connect
the dots I love the conversation it went
in ways that I didn't think it would go
I thought we'd spend the entire time
talking about who built the pyramids and
those things which you can definitely
find that like he's talked about that on
other podcasts but today was a lot of
information that I'm going to be honest
with you I've listened to a lot of his
stuff and I have not heard the stuff we
talked about today enjoy the peaceful
information that hopefully it brings to
you please hit subscribe and the bell
for notifications I'm curious what your
thoughts are about the episode and how
the information like lands with you fill
me in in the comments I love to read
those and enjoy this episode with
Matthias today's pretty intense partner
is athletic greens I take ag1 by
athletic greens literally every day I
gave ag1 a try because I wanted to
nourish my gut health I wanted to have
more energy I wanted to add more
micronutrients to my body I take it
first thing in the morning before I have
coffee and then before I go work out it
makes me feel so good I'm giving my body
the nutrition it craves if a
comprehensive solution is what you need
from your supplement routine then try
ag1 and get a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and get five free ag1 travel
packs with your first purchase go to
drinkag1.com pretty intense that's
drinkag1.com pretty intense check it out
I'm so excited I've been wanting to talk
to you for so long long the amount of
hours that I've spent listening to God
it was a couple of years ago that I feel
like I was listening to a podcast that
you were on and I don't know if it was
Aubrey's or not it's you've done you've
done a lot with Aubry and it might have
been one of his I remember being like so
fascinated and especially by like
dimensions in your explanation and I was
like oh my God this guy is fascinating
today I was with Robert Grant I know
yeah and and he thought he he mentioned
you and I said I think I have a call
with her today and said no way so he was
like
he was like
all combined Soul families feel like
they're uniting I feel like there's like
ancient Soul families like really
finding each other yeah and now it's
faster
it's getting very fast yes why is that
well it's basically because
um the planet now it's tuning to a
frequency that everyone can be connected
to uh before everything was like cut
like disconnected
and it's a natural process of this
connection and
going to sleep and waking up that's a
that's a natural process in the planet
it's like a Long Winter let's say a long
invarnation uh hibernation of um of of
Consciousness
um
so now everything is waking up again
and
it speeds the way we are connecting to
one another so as more people wakes up
suddenly the frequency starts to connect
all the people that usually weren't
connected
um again so
uh it's a faster connection today
what will be the What is the point of
the connection happening what will
happen as a result of that
well the
it's not that there is a goal
um like for example uh I like to compare
it with the seasons
so it's like it's like uh we are coming
from winter so that means that we have
started in Spring
and the point of spring basically is to
produce flowers that opens in order to
reproduce and create more seeds and
fruits that can produce seeds that can
sow and then create more trees and
expand the forest and expand the
pollination and suddenly more animals
can grow and more life can be expanded
but it doesn't mean that it will be
always like that so summer will be to
enjoy it to to to enjoy what we have
been creating and sewing during the
Spring
and then Autumn which is the depth of
that system in order to restore energy
so all the plans go inside again we have
to get into hibernation in order to
process that information
and rest for a period of time that can
be disconnected from all the rest of the
environment because you have to go to
the process Within
and then again spring so what is the
purpose of connection it's basically
because now we reach a moment in not in
humanity but in
planet history that we start to
leave spring again
so
in the mind concept of um
of this planet in the mind or in the
Consciousness seasons of this planet we
are beginning again with spring so
that's why we are waking up we are
blossoming again and showing our
potentials to everybody trying to open
where it was hidden within to the
outside so it's like a lot of flowers
opening so we can recognize each other
better now I like to look at a lot of
things in the way that they happen as
being sort of fractal in nature that
there is the seasons within our own year
but then there's like a a larger fractal
aspect of the seasons that might be
a thousand years exactly is that kind of
how what you're referring to as a season
yeah and you can divide the Four Seasons
for example you can divide them in 24
000 years
so you have fractals of a long time of
period like you are Maybe
5 600 years in Winter and then 5 600
years in Spring
so
um now we are starting spring and spring
doesn't start in one day even if there
is an equinox that says to you yeah you
started actually
many flowers starts to Blossom like a
few weeks before and others start to
Blossom like a month after that day so
we can we can tell that because of all
the Awakening process that we have been
living since a hundred hundred
a hundred and fifty years ago like
um
since since early
since the 20th century or late 19th
century uh Humanity started to wake up
very fast
and um and even if for us today
everything looked like weird and crazy
and uh dark in the 18th and the 19th
century actually was the beginning of
the waking up so it was the beginning of
the spring and it took 200 years
um of the beginning of the spring so
um that's why most of the change that we
have been living
in this
in this past 200 years has been the
beginning of what we are living now yeah
and we have the contrast now to waking
up so it does look dark
yeah uh the darkness that we see that we
perceive is because there is so much
light now that you can see the mess that
we have done for 5 000 years
um it's like it's like you have been
kind of blind inside a room and you have
been putting all the furniture and and
all the the papers you were throwing it
away because you had no idea where to
put the stuff and suddenly someone
starts to open the window and you
suddenly say oh my gosh this is a mess
it's not because today is a mess it's
because you have been creating this mess
for 5 000 years and suddenly now you see
it yeah it's not that this is not a dark
time this is a light time
so you can now become aware of all the
things that we have been doing
so what are we that we have these
cyclical Seasons like what are we why
does that even happen
well
everything is a cycle in the reality so
everything is like a heartbeat
everything lives
periods process
um in the in the universe you have like
four beats uh that measures every
process through time which is expression
experimentation integration and
Transcendence so everything in the
universe Express itself Express means
that it goes out of a pressure so
something explodes and goes out
so that explosion is expression
something that
goes out of this pressure that was
inside
and then and then something experiment
experiment experiment means to go around
a circle that's the meaning of
experimentation this is the action of
going that of going through the
perimeter okay so um so it means that
you are
going around uh
trying to check what has been exploded
what has been expressed
then integration is to put together all
the things that you have been looking
around into the center again to
understand
why it exploded why it was expressed
and then Transcendence is to make make
something different from this from the
experimentation that you got from that
so you said oh now it makes sense and I
will transform this into something
different
so
um
that's a process that everything goes
through
um a long time
and this process is something that in
nature has been called spring summer
winter so the explosion has to be the
spring or like how do the seasons
combine yeah the expression is the
spring or something the Expressions the
spring yeah and also the fire
related to uh the universe like the four
elements that we have in nature
everything that is a pattern of four is
related to this structure of time and
space creates our perception of
um of uh existence so basically what are
we we are basically an expression a
fractal of that movement the essence of
the being
that
it's in the process of forming itself
and the process of being of taking form
is how we call information
so basically we are constant information
is a process of data that has been
uh organized in different ways so it's a
constant process of information that
creates energy
and that energy is movement so basically
we are essence
that exist which means to go out from
where you are
in order to create information
towards energy and that energy creates
matter so we are the result of data that
is trying to figure out its own place or
way
which makes us in this planet Earth
um each human
it's a neuron of a planet that is
thinking
a neuron yeah
um so
in the in that state of expression
experimentation integration and
experience and Transcendence
um we are basically the neurons living
those process
of a planet actually the planet is
thinking not humans
we are just a fractal a result of a
living being that started to think
and uh we are in the process of
experiencing what it is to think
so it's not that we are a species on a
rock
we are actually The Rock in a process of
evolution you said something that I
heard that like was like damn that's
good um and I think you got it in a
plant medicine ceremony it might have
been recently it might have been the
Ayahuasca and whatever else that I think
you just did a journey
um for the group but it was you said
that we are the AI of the mineral world
yes so would that
is that something that happened then I
can't I don't know exactly when you
discovered that or had that
um information come through but is that
what you're referring to a little bit
yeah well this is something I always
knew somehow
um
but uh recently I put it together into
my body like
um I integrate that that before was
separated in the mind and uh through the
process of Ayahuasca I was able to feel
it not just thinking yeah yeah and when
you when you become something you
believe
that's a totally different story it's
like if you are
if you are remembering the story for the
first time
um so my body recognized that truth that
I knew before but that this is the first
time that I could put words on it sure
basically
if you think
uh in a very cold way
um
you are made up with minerals yeah we
are basically
or energy and minerals collapsed into
this density yeah basically basically
the energy have have created like we can
say also we are light because basically
um all the minerals that exist is just
an exchange of energy between particles
and those particles are the result of
more much more deeper energy until you
reach the dark energy and then the dark
matter and all this these other Realms
that are not physical that are
energetic so if we are talking about the
third dimension and that exchange of
energy the first thing that creates that
exchange of energy is the mineral Realm
so the mineral realm is the first realm
on being created after energy
we can we can call the atomic realm
there's also the atomic realm of course
um which is a compact structure of of
energy
but when we talk about the planet as
rock
um we can say that every combination of
the mineral has created life basically
when you go to the prokaryote story of
how the first cells have been created is
actually different minerals that started
to interact to one another in order to
storage energy
so uh that that was the whole the whole
process was to put together a lot of
energy and they started to figure out a
way to storage much more energy when
they mixed each other and they use each
other
so that created a single the minerals
you mean mixed the minerals yeah so they
created this this link that we call love
which is basically the exchange of
energy
the exchange of energy to one another is
the pulse the constant pulse of
exchanging different amounts of energy
to one another so I have a lot of energy
you have less energy let's share that
energy and that
it's love
so so if love dies out or if there is no
love it's because there's not enough
energy towards each other
basically basically it's a waste of it's
it's that you rise you raise an amount
of energy
that maybe for example when you become
more conscious you need a lot of energy
from a higher so you will need people
that has the same amount of energy or
higher in order to transcend to this to
the next step that's why we break up
it's like you you need to keep changing
because you need to exchange different
kinds of energy just to keep evolving uh
and basically that's that's how the
mineral realm found a way to evolve by
exchanging different amounts of energy
and making Alchemy
yeah the the constant Alchemy and uh
they improve in a way that they created
organs that exchange that energy
Evolution
they improve in a way that created
something that we call
um that that it's basically hormones and
the hormones created this flashes of
energy that we call emotion
so
basically the constant movement of
energy is what we call soul
and the soul never ends because it's a
constant exchange of energy
through the mineral rod
and uh
it's the data it's basically the data
that's why we remember our past lives
is because we never died actually is
because we just being uploaded to the
cloud yes
yeah so talk about that transition then
of because we do forget you luckily
remember remember but like most everyone
forgets most everything but do we forget
because
we don't have the contrast within
ourself to know what our reality would
be like in a in another mind in another
experience but we have old so like
people that just seem to get it there's
people that are have incredible talents
of things there's people that seem like
old souls there's there's feelings about
like oh I feel very connected to Egypt I
feel very connected to the Vikings I
feel very connected to Mayan culture and
then there's other people that feel
connected to Japan or Russia or you know
whatever and so do we really forget it's
not that we forget is that the cells has
this mechanism of survival
that makes makes the bodies torch the
information in a way that doesn't bother
them to survive in environment that they
are creating right now like for example
if you are now living in the states and
you have to and yourselves know that you
have to work in order to
uh to pay your taxes and to live in the
states and to uh reach reach a huge
amount of people in order to
um to expand what you know now or I
don't know whatever project you have
today
um to remember that you were fighting a
war in Sweden as a Viking
uh I'm gonna help you it doesn't help it
doesn't help because yeah you would be
fighting a word that doesn't worth it
now you know it doesn't make any sense
so basically what the cells do is I
don't need this now
so I will keep it storage
so I can put all my energy
focus on what I need to know now
and for example when you are a baby what
you need to know is
how to call your mom because you're
hungry
it does so if you if you when you are
three years old remember that you were
an artist in the Renaissance
uh it doesn't work because what you need
is to cry in order to get food so
yourself basically are trying to survive
all the time because the constant
movement of energy is about not what you
know is about what you're moving
so because you're moving through time
and in order to move through time you
need to be born again and you need to
transform your body to die to be born
um and until you find a way to not to
die anymore because you can die
in life
um so regenerate all all your cells
without the need of dying
until we reach that process
um the cells needs to survive so it they
need to adapt every time that they
change the body
that the energy changes bodies and
transforms itself they need to re-adapt
to the new environment and that and that
is a huge amount of energy that every
cell needs to pay attention to so if you
remember everything that you have done
it's like it's like if every time that
you are talking
you have to remember what you learned
when you were three years old and your
mom were telling you like Mom you know
like
um like well man I I felt that I did a
um a psilocybin Journey a guided one and
I did a pretty big dose of five grams
and
um in this space like I and I was out
for probably about two hours like just
laying there under blankets one of the
first things that I came to to say and I
didn't say a lot but
I was like there's so much information
in here like and when I I was in that
space before I sat up and talked was I
was like oh my God there's so much to
remember in here because every question
had an answer like immediately and so I
got up and I was like in that space I I
literally said like you know
how am I going to take all this
information back to the humans and
they're like you don't have to don't
worry about it like just just relax just
just chill like just be in your
experience enjoy it yeah and so it also
gave me an indication that
that might be why we forget
that's what I thought then as I was like
man we have to forget because we can't
hold this amount of data it would fry us
so as as much enlighted you get you get
useless for this dimension and and uh so
you you transcend to The Fifth Dimension
or to the seventh Dimension
but you get useless for the third
dimension So eventually if you don't
separate yourself and concentrating what
you're doing now you wouldn't be able to
do what you are doing now you wouldn't
be able to create the person you are now
enjoy the reality that you have created
for yourself
and also to help
different people to reconnect to
themselves in different ways when you
connect to the Divine everything is one
and you can see everything and suddenly
you have a complete understanding of
everything but you have no ways and why
is impossible because all the forces
together is equal zero will you embody
Oneness so just like you said I took it
into my body like once you become the
one there's nothing to even say because
you're like no no they know like it's
all the same there's nothing to say
that's why when enlightened people comes
back and someone asks how was it they
just breathe and uh and and they just
say a smile and they just say breathe
and uh and you don't understand it
because it's so complicated because it's
like why breathe
because it's it's Oneness you you start
to feel the whole the
the whole thing so when we forget
what we start to do is to concentrate in
a way
of understanding the unity
which means that there is a lot of
people that will ReSound with what I'm
saying
but there's a lot of people that won't
ReSound with what I'm saying but will
ReSound with what you are saying
so
depending on the frequency of the people
they will reach to the same truth
through different channels
that have been divided and had to forget
many of the parts in order to
concentrate in one way because there's a
lot of people or a lot of things that
we'll need to reach the unity through
the way they understand yeah and
everybody it's almost like everybody
kind of speaks a different frequency
language you go and speak Italian and
try to explain to an Arab person in the
middle of chat that what is unity
so no way so you have to
you have to find someone that learned
the language of that region and learn
the ways of that region in order to
transmit to those aspects and sometimes
that aspect is Art sometimes it's music
sometimes science sometimes spirituality
so then do by doing that is that what
helps you wake up to remember is when
you connect with others with that
frequency it heightens it it makes it
stronger
yeah and it's important to understand
what remember means yeah
um
because remember is not a goal it's not
that we should remember or we must
remember because we forgot actually
remember means to put the members
together
again that's what it means the other
word for remember is record
or remind which is to go back to the
mind or to go back to the heart those
are the meanings of of recording
remembering
um reminding
these three meanings tells you that you
have lost yourself
so you don't know where you are so you
are doing other stuff or you are
struggling in your life because you
don't know how to connect with yourself
so remembering helps you to go back to
yourself not to the source or to the
universe whatever it's just go back to
yourself which is to record enter the
recordings that is inside of you record
means to go back to the heart in Latin
so everything that is recorded inside of
you you can only access if you go back
to your heart
that's the meaning so
so if you want to activate your own
potential you have to go back to your
heart to who you are and basically who
you are is just an idea which is remind
remind yourself Who You Are
and it's not about going back to the
source or getting out of this Matrix or
whatever it's just go back to you where
you belong to to your own Center and
from there you will find the pattern to
start being your own creator
is there a parallel with the chakras in
the body and where we are in time that
we're moving up into the heart
and how the heart will then help us
remember ourselves back together
is that does that play into it at all
because I feel like I've heard some
things regarding like being moving up
moving up the chakras moving up in in
energy and this is sort of that
transition point where we we are able to
then access more
more higher frequencies and into that
sort of Love frequency all the music
that we listen it's in 440 Hertz yeah
so that means that that music is
resounding in the throat chakra
so it means that we are just
insane but we don't have the essence of
what we say
so we communicate we we express we are
saying many things we are shouting we
are expressing ideas but none of them
has a heart
um so one of the frequencies that we
have to align with is 432 Hertz which is
here
so when you're aligning to the to that
chakra so that that frequency you start
to listen the heartbeat in frequency
so basically you align with the chakra
that instead of expressing just that
Express from here you see these bowls
back here
they're all Alchemy balls and the first
time that I went to go get them or I
went to go pick some out it was a
process sit down meditate ground
and she she plays them with my eye and
I'm playing I'm sitting there with my
eyes closed and I could I had no I this
is you know you learn I had no idea that
the bowl was a no and that note
correlated with a chakra I just didn't I
didn't know that I just knew that when
she played it I was like whoa I feel
that in my heart I was like oh I feel
that like really like high like Crown
like it feels like it's expanding and so
all the bowls kind of have
they have their note but then they also
go a direction they're positive or
negative you're talking about frequency
and aligning and so you know there's
there's I there's so much overlap with
music and sound and color and all kinds
of different things they they they have
a they they correlate with the body
yeah so well basically all the reality
can be described as a symphony
uh because everything is entangled in
vibration
so everything one of the laws of the
universe is rhythm and vibration so
there are two laws that everything has a
rhythm which is the heartbeat or any
beat
and you have the vibration which is uh
everything is vibrating uh so everything
makes a sound and when everything is
aligned or in harmony you can listen to
music
so
um basically we are music it's just that
we don't listen the sounds
but our bodies exist through rhythms
pulses and vibrations
that make possible the energy that makes
possible an atom or particles and so on
so
um
uh every movement and everything that we
have inside is correlated to one of
these hurts and frequencies so when you
tune in the outside that without a
specific frequency
your inner frequency starts to tune
to tune back and would you do that
suddenly
a code of information
inside your cells opened so you start to
feel an emotion
or you change from heat to cold or from
cold to heat so your body starts to
react to the vibration to the music uh
sometimes it's a rhythm depending on the
culture
but when you do sounds different
information from yourself starts to
awake because we are resonance so it's
like it's like tuning Forks so
um that's why with some people
you you get along very easy and with
some others you cannot even if the
person is a good person sometimes you
cannot tolerate the presence but it's
just because the tunings are different
maybe you are in the note E and they are
in the node a or whatever so uh you
cannot hear the same song and when they
talk
you can you you just hear dissonance
and uh we call that like I don't really
sound with this you know yeah but we've
got a way of understanding I don't
ReSound with it yeah the bad way is that
if I don't ReSound it must not be true
for sure because it doesn't ReSound with
me but actually it is the truth but it
is the truth in another resonance that
doesn't come with your own so it doesn't
mean that it's not true it's just
another one yeah well that was
definitely like
with the mushrooms that time I saw
myself as what seemed like a waveform
basically and the first thing I felt was
cold and I was like oh well it's not
real it's just a waveform intersecting
and this is the information I'm getting
from this intersection of waves I'm like
no it's okay it's okay you're cold like
just put the blanket on it's like just
this is just an experience and that was
like the information was that food was
like that like oh a mango is just like
this kind of frequency intersection and
that's what people are and so sometimes
things are just like a fun Rhythm right
yeah and sometimes and sometimes they
work totally in sync and sometimes just
not at all not at all like that does not
compute does not resonate like you said
um so is that accurate I mean is like a
waveform oh like was I was that
information and that space that I got
accurate yeah it's all waves it's all
waves of vibration that Express
themselves into
patterns and those patterns created
energy and that energy creates matter so
we are basically constant waves we are
not separate things it's a constant way
we are just we are just an upper wave of
a lot of people that have been born and
died born and die and we are just
diving this tide of frequency and we are
taking benefit of it and then our energy
will go to the other one and so on so
it's a constant movement of frequencies
not that you are born and then you stop
existing and no it's a constant movement
of waves that interact like in an ocean
it's like when you see an ocean the sea
you see this billions of tiny waves that
interact with one another and there are
there are huge currents or small
currents so
um and uh so many drops of water and
imagine that each one of us is a drop of
water in an ocean so
we are moving along all connected and we
think we are separated but actually it's
all one thing I want to talk about Egypt
and I think you just went to Egypt
didn't you I just came four days ago
there's so many questions about Egypt
one of the things I thought of when you
said
different frequencies and energies and
then I
is that I think about like how you know
was that part of how the stones were cut
and how the pyramids were built is that
they were just in a different
time in history where frequency and
energy was just in a different space and
at a different level and that's what
made that possible so that's kind of
what like made my mind go to Egypt but
first off how was Egypt was I mean I
went there two years ago and I I've been
wanting to go to Egypt since I was a
teenager
um so uh for me I was so glad to finally
get there but um was your did you have
an amazing time was it was it great or
do you not like going
well I I lived there for a year
um it it became my home
um in the past life so I Feel Home there
every time that I go is is an amazing
trip that connects me with new
information with New Missions that I
have to do so Egypt basically is guiding
me all the time in what I must do
um in all this life
so
I really connect with with the place and
and this past time I've been like like
10 or 11 days or a bit more I think
um
on this cruise with a lot of people that
I have no idea that I was I would join
uh Cruz my guides told me it's time to
come back and you have to go now and
um and everything worked for me to be
there that's the way it goes when you're
doing what you should be doing right
it's the way it goes it moves easily I
met a lot of important people that
uh that helped me understand
different parts of my mission so I knew
that I had to go there to listen to
people not to talk to people
um and um and it was really nice to
listen and to understand why
um I had to be there in these past weeks
which was well it's a very long story
but uh to summarize it to summarize it I
I have been brought there because
um
I basically I am not just working for
spirituality but mainly for to create a
new Society here
and your understanding of society and
um and I know that that needs to start
in South Egypt there are many things
that brings me there and
there are there is a huge weird project
that I'm working on
um that eventually I will share but now
it's still like
in a place that it's weird to share
so
um but the idea is to start to to create
a new state of consciousness but not not
a state of being a real State
um
like a country right right right like
yeah like Arizona or California or
yeah so America yeah or what or some
other fun name that you'll come up with
yeah today we we came up with the name
of mitochondria
I'm trying to put together all the
projects to make a presentation to the
people that are willing to join so they
understand all the parts of the of the
project
um which is how to create
a new State of Consciousness uh the
first one in the world
um that would be a network and would
start in Egypt
so
um I have to to design first idea and
the next step basically I think that I
will download the ways to doing that in
the next three weeks because I'm well in
one week I'm going to to the North Pole
um
so uh
yeah so I'm going to the North Pole to
are you gonna go see if there's a hole
up there and if there's actually a way
to get to inner earth is there an inner
earth
no no and that's not in the road I I'm
I'm going on a cruise but not that far
I'm going to zwalk
and uh to the northern part of salbard
um
and um
so
um it's one of the places to connect
with the with the space
um actually all the all the signals and
the internet uh is connected through
solver which is a weird thing too to
know what is it called say that again
it's an island in in Norway
like a state inside of Norway with
autonomy
um and it's it's 600 kilometers 700
kilometers from the North Pole in the
Arctic Ocean
and um there's only one CG there a small
village and uh but all the internet
connections
goes there like the main important
internet connections and satellite
connections
um that we use around the world come
from there and it's the is that is the
only place in the world that we have
um
and Noah's Ark an actual Noah's Ark that
is buried inside the permafrost uh with
all the seats in the world just in case
everything dies in the planet this
valver is the only place where we can
restart the whole planet so now an
actual ancient old Noah's ark or meaning
like metaphorically speaking us a seed
for everything yeah there's a seed for
everything so this is something we've
created as like a detail for when
someone pushes the wrong damn button
exactly
we have cryogenically frozen
yeah but it's naturally preserved
because there's no there's nothing
inside just the eyes of the permafrost
so they are they are naturally storage
so this isn't that on purpose this
wasn't done on purpose it was hard on
purpose yeah there's all you can see is
the door okay that goes inside the
mountain and nobody can go there
yeah are you gonna go there
I've been there I've been there but not
inside I've been at the door many times
for me that place means the connection
with the crown chakra of the planet
and uh and the third eye uh also so it's
a place to
have Clarity in the mind and to expand
to the space and time and everything and
so
um I had this chance of of going there
and I think it's perfect that they
changed my dates of the trip I was
supposed to do it in 2020 and they
changed it because of kovid and
uh they put it now so it makes sense
that wise now why do you think there's
so much attention on Egypt right now it
seems like that it seems like there's a
lot of it always it's been always always
yeah Egypt Egypt is the mother
of our civilizations
uh the Nile denial was like the the main
spiritual path that people took to
understand who they are
so that's why every civilization uh in
the Middle East
went to the Nile to do that process so
from the very first human being that
walked along the Nile understanding
itself in every one of our cells
we have the Nile path Within
because every human the first humans in
the world in order to expand through the
world had to go through the Nile
so there is no one in the world that had
no cell with the memory of having taken
the path of denial
the first human another in another life
you're saying like at some point in time
this
Soul stream Essence all human cells all
human cells that exist today in these
eight billion people in the world for
the in order to go to the rest of the
world from Africa they had to walk along
the Nile
so in order to go back to the first path
that Humanity took in order to expand to
the outside from there within
they had to touch the Nile because when
people came from Africa the only way to
cross
to the other side was along the Nile
the only way to go to Middle East to
Europe
to Asia then to Australia then through
Siberian Americas and through the
Pacific Ocean to South America
they all had to cross the Nile so
where did humans first come from or was
the or is the version of human that we
know
well no let's back up let's start with
they started humans started in Africa is
what you're saying right women started
in Africa okay how did that happen how
did that happen of course we have been
updated I mean right right we've been
genetically modified is this guy okay
yeah but the main cells the main humans
the first actual humans
were born in Africa and from Africa they
started to expand and they started to be
modified
in Middle East in Siberia uh in the
Americas we have been
in Encounters in constant constant
encounters with other species from other
places that have provide us that had
download information into us that had um
but the main species that created the
humans the first cells were in Africa
so that's where the hours our species
appear so we so the base so there's a
there's a part of
the this human
experience that is native
yeah is that just sort of the
the cells learning process of like
creating the organs and then it just
kept expanding and growing and
creating a human yeah and then naturally
the first thing was naturally in this
world but naturally is
it's very weird to say because
um our design
was
created from the sixth dimension
so
some sometimes the thing is
when we say aliens
created humans
we usually tend to to think that aliens
use the same thing
as a human would use to create a species
like
taking a rabbit
taken to a lab
modify something make a mix and uh
mild navile or whatever and then put it
in syringe in it and wait for it to
transform or open it and change
something inside so that's how humans
would do it
but people from other places right other
dimensions
from other worlds they don't usually
travel from one world to the another
they use interdimension
realities in order to do something
so basically there are many species that
never visit
this world but they modified the life in
this world through the sixth Dimension
so
uh I see
so that's why because we're existing on
all these planes right like
exactly and there are some species in
other worlds that evolved to be able to
to mold and to use this Dimension and in
the sixth Dimension there is no no space
so
in order to transform the Earth you
don't need a space a spaceship to come
to Earth
you just have to you just have to enter
the frequency of Earth and from where
you are modify the plant and the plant
will modify here through layers of time
so for them it's just a second
but for the for the Earth it could take
a million years yeah until the light is
modified
so that's why when we see as evolution
is actually a lab work in other planets
you know uh so why don't they just why
are why do we not get modified to the
point that we
are incapable of evil and destruction
and
disharmony why wouldn't we get modified
modified up
we need a glow up
hahaha
yeah it's basically it's like saying for
example
um
I want an apple but I don't want to wait
for the tree to grow
so you cannot make an apple
you have to wait for the seed
to be in the darkness and the pressure
of the earth to feel how to absorb the
nutrients and extend roots and first the
first thing that every being does in the
vegetal realm what is to go deep into
the darkness
because darkness is the one that has the
minerals the dark is the one that has
the potential
and you find the dark and the potential
through going against the force of the
earth and you have to feel the pressure
until you feel you are tight enough to
this reality to start growing up
so when you take the
the understanding of how a plant grows
you will understand why in order to
become an aware human being you first
have to go deep into the darkness
is it true then
that kind of like I was saying if we
hold all the information it's just like
system overload like we
we're not capable of taking the upgrade
needed to get to that space
we are doing it all right right but like
I mean in an instant we're not capable
of if you if you do it in an instance if
if you do it in an instant uh there's no
experimentation without experimentation
there's no Integra into integration yeah
there is no Transcendence so basically
you are breaking all the laws of time
and space in the third dimension and it
doesn't make any sense
for the third dimension so actually the
thinking would be why to even exist
you'd be useless back to your original
you'd be useless hopefully and there's
only one fun thing for an eternal being
to do
which is to limit itself
that's the only fun thing to do and yeah
it's like if you are Limitless
the only fun thing to do is to put a
limit
yeah it's like death like if you didn't
if you never died you wouldn't give life
much purpose exactly
actually there is no purpose so we had
to invent the idea of end to have a
purpose
so that's why we created the idea of
evil
to understand the light
we have to practice the bad things in
order to understand what is harmony if
you don't go through the stage of
listening
I don't know very hard metal music
you won't understand the balance of a
high frequency music for example right
and neither of them is fine
neither of them is the good one
so what is happening it's just different
frequencies to
tune in and to experience so I mean
again back to that like medicine Journey
it was like you're just here to
experience it
exactly so for the universe actually
evil doesn't exist
the the universe doesn't understand
the universe doesn't understand good
that's that's just something that we
created in order to know how to survive
evil can kill you so it's better not to
do evil it's better to do good things in
order to survive and doing the right
thing and the good thing brought us to
create real religions for us to create
culture for us to create patterns that
we are afraid of breaking so we are
trapped in the system because we are a
threat because we have to do the right
thing so what is the right
you know so so that then you start to
think oh maybe doing the right thing was
not the right thing
because we got trapped in our own system
so now we have to break it and we are
the bad guys because we have to break
the system right right right right yeah
so so that's why what is bad what is
good and
basically for the loss of the universe
and that thing actually is when you
break
the Free Will of others
and what is the what is the Free Will of
others the Free Will of others is
basically to allow the other
to exist
uh to allow the other to exist basically
when you kill someone or when you take
the freedom from someone you're breaking
the balance of that someone
for example for a need for nature uh
it's not bad to kill when you need
energy to eat
that's why all nature does it because
it's something natural
um but there's nothing in nature
actually that that actually create
slavery for example when when you start
to see the actions of evilness
um
in nature is when you start to see the
dissonance of that reality
because actually nature can kill because
of the need
but cannot kill because of a will so
only mind can kill because of a will
and uh when you are when you are
becoming aware that you can kill for fun
or that you can
do chaos taking life of others because
of fun then you start living the process
of this harmony with the environment
with nature and that's why a lot of
other white cells of the body starts to
fight back that cancer
it's like the immunological system the
white cells and we call it light beams
but actually our white cells of the body
so it's the immune system of the body
that suddenly runs towards the cancer
and the cancer basically tries to get
the cells and
and the body tries to survive and if the
body does doesn't survive it will it
will give
the information of how to do it next
time in the next body
so to get it better to do it right
exactly that's why for example the the
first humans a cold
for America for example the whole
America when they experience the first
cold
more people were killed because of his
niece
than because of the sore
well I've heard that we kind of
or existence to
um
like germs and bacteria and like and and
illnesses
hopefully we
the environment we live in everything
that we have here before was something
that killed us it was poison the oxygen
is poison
basically oxygen is something that
oxidize our our blood
so it it corrodes the body
killing the body
so basically what our cells learned in
the first stage of of life was how to
use a poison
as a way of a source of energy
so we um we we evolve there's an
interaction
yeah we evolved to to find a way to take
the energy from the poison
and we call that breathing
so basically uh the the the the the
plants extract the oxygen because it's a
poison the plant says I don't eat this
is is basically plant yeah
on the other cells we said this is a
poison so how do we survive this poison
that the plants are taken
way to use it how do we use it so we
started to use it as energy
it's like oil like uh petrol is that
like a form of alchemy then yeah it's an
alchemy that we evolved in order to so
everything bacteria viruses
um everything that we consider evil
where the reasons why the Next
Generation survived because our cells
started to understand
how to get better and better every time
that's why evil things are actually the
ones that makes us stronger is something
that you listen in every song you know
so
um
but even though we try to get rid of it
and actually for example
this is a very difficult difficult
thought to understand but the reason why
human rights exist
the European Union
with free trade exists
and the state of Israel exists is
because of Hitler
so we got so many good things
from an evil thing
yeah like so many transcendental ideas
and uh so so many
um the the whole Europe and World they
said we cannot stand this anymore we
cannot we cannot produce this anymore so
they create all these structures to
create Free Speech free right
so we we didn't have that before right
at the point in that and said you don't
have this is it a human thing is it a
third dimensional thing to have this
light and dark good and evil you know
this Duality no it's it's everywhere
it's never Dimension it's just that it's
just that in the in the main creation we
call that
the void and the whole so the whole the
complete the unity is what we call the
light or the good
and the void is what we call the bad the
dark the Shadows
but actually from the point of view of
the universe is
is not that
um
it's they look the same
it's just that one is black and the
other one is white what are we working
towards
oh as humans we are basically one of the
aware
species of a planet that can spread
through the entire galaxy
to create a whole expansion of
consciousness
to become aware to become part of the
Creator and to be able eventually
to be
our own creators like a source yeah
we're basically a virus
that its goal is to expand to the entire
galaxy and to make the Galaxy
into a source
into a new source of creation we're just
a seed like a tiny little virus that is
good for the Galaxy so does that support
like a Multiverse theory that this is
happening this is is happening has
happened will happen in many many many
other universes yeah it's so much
so much that is happening have happened
will happen
it's so much that it's impossible to
explain it's impossible to relate to and
eventually
when you get it you understand that
there's no purpose
you understand that there's no goal
that actually it doesn't matter
and
when you think about it as a human that
all the purpose that a human has in its
life basically is to survive and to live
longer and to love everybody and to do
something that mine
that means in the world
so
this is a very destructive thought
is is is terrible
but
when you feel it not as a destructive
thought but as a creative thought
suddenly something happens that is
amazing
which is
when you see that there are so many
options and things in the universe
and there is no purpose in all of them
because they are actually not happening
at all they're just projections of a
mind that is trying to express something
that is within
and that actually The Eternity is
playing with limits in order to be able
to express to experience itself because
otherwise it's impossible
because the void cannot experience
itself Without Limits
so you understand that the only purpose
that we created in the universe was
limits
and we are fighting the limits
which we created in order to exist
otherwise we wouldn't exist
so when you take away all the limits and
you find it again with the universe with
the cosmos you find yourself Timeless
infinite
spaceless
and suddenly you are nothing you are a
void
and when you're a void you can feel two
different things
desperation of this doesn't have any
sense or the other which is
I am I am I am I am everything I am all
potentiality so basically when you get
there
you become free
because now you will enjoy every second
of everything because you know now that
you are not trapped in anything that you
are actually
just experiencing
a second that is
beautiful as the eternity
and
you become free because you enjoy every
breath because you enjoy everyone every
walk you enjoy to create projects you
enjoy to share with others
without a need of survival without the
need of having a goal you just enjoy
doing things because you enjoy creating
because you are the Creator
so it's a you have to go through a very
rough time
until you get to that point that
for example I have this project we have
to create the first state of
consciousness and blah blah and all
these things but I I before I was doing
it because I was in a rush like I have
to do it because otherwise this planet
is going to be wrong all these things
yeah the ego the survival was trying to
say and after my year in Egypt I went
370 days in a row inside the pyramid
and uh
and uh after all this meditation and all
this preparation
and all this information that I received
suddenly I was like
wait a moment I'm doing this because I
enjoy this not because I have to
it's because I decided to leave my life
like if it is a movie or a story so I am
sharing
I found life I don't want to do like a
life of survival I want to create
projects that have meanings because I
love to live like like if I am in a
movie
so that that that Set Me Free from
everything that I'm doing and everything
is moving so fast
that's the thing it starts going faster
the more because you're more in the flow
yeah so I want you to talk about that a
little bit because that's something that
is becoming far more regular for me and
it's like the more fun I
line up for myself and the more cool
things I do and the more I just do what
I want to do the more the universe sends
you like totally big signs that you
could never orchestrate yourself it's
like I take like the huge Winks from the
universe like there you go there you go
I just made your life better didn't I
wait you could never do it right there
you go and I always think that's more on
track but it it's truly when I'm doing
more of the things that I enjoy doing
whether it's a vacation or work just
like picking my picking my life that
more of that happens and so why does why
is that like how does that correlate
remember we are basically energy
or vibration we are vibration
so
when you take a decision of for example
having fun
when you do your projects or your goals
in life yeah a bit of suffering so you
are in a high vibration
right High vibration because basically
when you are happy and you're set your
intention of being happy
uh not because something is happening
outside that makes you happy that's a
reaction
in order for you to become an action you
have to decide I am going to be happy
today because otherwise you live in a
constant reaction of something happening
outside
so it's like you wake up and even if
it's a shitty day you say I'm gonna be
happy today and you start to laugh
that creates an action and when you
create an action you create a chemical
reaction in your brain that tells to the
hypo hypothesis gland which you you call
it petrol campus hippocampus yep and the
pituitary gland so you tell to that land
hey
I'm happy so that gland will tell to
your genitals first hey he's happy
then we'll tell to your adrenal and your
um pancreas
hey this person is happy so you start to
sing close to the blood
so you start to feel happy yeah this is
like Bruce Lipton stuff like you change
your biology yeah so you start to by
just saying I'm happy the body says oh
we need glucose because the body is
happy so you start to have energy
because the pancreas starts to produce
glucose and suddenly you start to feel
like yeah I have energy
so it's a practice you have to practice
this it's like it's like going on a
bicycle you know when you're a child uh
it's something you have to practice like
learning how to talk it's not just that
and when you start to have that
communication
with your body like saying I have I'm
calm now like listening to your
heartbeat like now I'm calm and suddenly
you start to tell to your body how to
act
and when you start to have that
communication what are you doing you are
basically manipulating your own
frequency you are tuning yourself into a
frequency is high frequency
because now you can
you can
go up but if you wake up and say I'm
ugly I'm I don't know what to do uh I'm
lost today I'm sad
um so your body will start to react to
that your body will start to create that
reality of you through the hormones so
um your hormones will start to react to
that your position also if you sit like
this instead of like this your brain
your brain when you are like this
your brain feels this person is sad
and because you are closing your your
shoulders your and you're using this
protection so so the body interpretates
that you're protecting from something so
you start to feel fear and tyrants
but if you are like this your body says
this person is standing up so we have to
face something with the chest
so uh it's just to fold your mind a
little bit with intention so your body
follows that lead
and uh
when you do that suddenly
you tune to a reality
in a frequency that you can only
perceive what is in that frequency
it's like tuning a radio
so so you can also see you can see more
of the positive in people even because
you're tuned to those frequencies and
when someone I don't know treats you in
a bad way yeah
instead of feeling sad you know so you
suddenly start to to like go out like to
react to that and and see the code oh
yeah that person sent me this because of
this then just happened and you start to
laugh about it you start to feel to to
notice like the synchronicities around
you totally so
um that's why it all starts not from the
outside it starts from a decision that
you make in your mind and that Tunes
your body into that reality of being
creator of being in harmony with with
everything I mean when I wake up in the
morning and I've been doing it the last
few days for some reason and I don't
know why I don't do it every day because
it works
every day I do it but when I wake up and
I think of like two or three
energies that I want to feel that day
like I want to feel everything move go
really smoothly and I want to laugh a
lot today
and like just have fun
that's it set the intention without fail
literally that's what happens that day
yeah like I literally said that this
morning and it was probably like six or
seven a.m and I'm a rose I'd I hadn't I
was I had just done a little workout and
I came in and I was like oh yeah I said
your intention and like from that point
on I was just goofy like I'm texting and
I'm like God I'm funny you know like it
just was my day and it's not complicated
it's just hard to remember and hard to
have the discipline
yeah it's just said an intention
yeah and the rest will follow yeah but
it's a practice as I said it's not that
because sometimes people say oh like I
will do that this way for example a lot
of people I've heard a lot of people
saying I uh the law of attraction
for example
um The Law of Attraction works the Law
of Attraction but it's not a lot of
attraction
is not just asking for things
the law of attraction is related to
seven other laws in the universe
that usually people don't follow so the
only way in which the Law of Attraction
works is if you work with the other
seven laws is it the Hermetic principles
yes the Hermetic principles yeah so you
cannot attract to you what you don't
ReSound
you should you cannot attract
attract fear not in the right rhythm of
what you are trying to attract with you
cannot attract if you don't create the
cost for that consequence you cannot try
something if you don't have the Mind Set
for that something you cannot if you
don't correspond to that something so
there are so many other laws
that sometimes
because
we want things fast
um we think that they don't require
practice it's just a magic thing
but actually there are many things that
you have to do in order to get there
it's like it's like learning how to
drive like learning how to talk
you have to practice I know that there's
like no goal for all this but if we want
to get into that flow state if we want
to enjoy this experience more and more
what would you recommend some of those
practices or disciplines be that will
help people do that
well there are three main things that
um we should all practice at least once
a day
which is
um
first of all remember that
you become what you eat
so
um your cells takes the energy to become
you to nourish the DNA according to the
energy that you set in your body so the
minerals proteins the things that you
put in your body and also the intentions
and also what you see what you watch
what you hear
what you feel
in your day so what you put in your body
through your mouth Through Your Eyes
through your ears
through the five senses yeah so
at least we have to think
how to nourish one of those senses in a
good way
maybe today I would say today I will
carry someone or myself
like
um to nourish through the touch yeah
um today I will
I don't know cook something that smells
really good or that makes me remember
about my childhood or something
whatever or
this tiny things
that nourish the body because basically
your dni your DNA
storage the energy from what you eat
from each one of the five senses
so think about how you nourish
at least with one of those five every
day
okay tiny little things
uh because you will become that
[Music]
um
the second thing is related to the
energy and it's breathing
at least one minute today
try to be aware of your breath
so when you're aware of your breath
and you start to breathe only through
the nose
and take the time to feel how the air
goes in how your lungs
work how your heartbeat changes the
Rhythm
how the air refresh your body and then
goes back out
very smoothly always
the nose in and out through the nose
so all as long as you can like breathing
in very slow holding in as much as you
can but not like not like if you are
under the water like very softly and
then
exhaling very softly too
so at least one minute and then you
start to add more minutes I mean you
really do this when you go to sleep at
night and it would probably put you to
sleep exactly yeah
and uh that helps to your body to enter
a frequency a right frequency
so uh so it Tunes all the glands it
Tunes all your bloodstream so your soul
starts to find balance through breathing
which is it cool all your emotions
starts to find balance just
by breathing
and the third thing is at least
for whatever try to laugh at once at
least once a day
like a joke
um
whatever yeah with yourself with others
whatever but try to laugh about
something once a day because that
creates a
a spark in your brain
uh that creates that produces all these
hormones in your brain that makes you
feel like in an orgasmic State
um
so it's good to
just smile at least if you cannot laugh
but try to force a smile because when
you force your smile all your muscles in
your in your face tells you to your body
this person
he's smiling so so maybe Smile as much
as you can until you start to laugh
about at yourself
um
it's good to laugh
of yourself like
your silly things
um so at least once a day
one minute of conscious breathing
laugh about something and be aware of
what are you
taking from the five senses from one of
the five senses those are
that I think that's very easy to do but
it's the beginning of a step two to
awareness yeah oh those are good I like
those even just when you were talking
about breathing I just like took deep
breaths and I was like God that feels so
good like it's so easy it's so simple
um because the mechanism
but the way it works is is easy so
um and we forget because we we are so
much in our minds and trying to figure
out stuff and how to survive and how to
do this or that or be greater than
we forget that those tiny little things
are the ones that are not taught and are
the main ones to made us up
there's so many other places we could go
but I think that was a great way to
great way to wrap things up for this
time around hopefully we can talk again
I I mean I didn't I I don't know who
built the pyramids I don't know why they
were built exactly I mean I haven't in
intuition I didn't hear about all the
dimension descriptions
so I hope you'll agree to come back
another time so we can talk about those
but for now I think that that was really
really good
hopefully people should feel peaceful
right like there there's not there's not
nothing to do other than enjoy this life
all the rest of information like the
pyramids the purposes of the countries
and
all the rest of the things are just
decoration to these main ones like
um
um it's important to know all these
things but not trivial like it's not the
main thing
um they are just things that helps to
understand the environment
the history to look at yourself to
understand better the purpose
um but
they they don't nourish the real core of
it so
yeah do the internal work
all right Matthias thank you very much
thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button